Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is a followup work to a technique we
have talked about earlier.
We have seen how different creatures learned
to walk, and their movement patterns happened
to be robust to slight variations in the terrain.
In this work, we imagine these creatures as
a collection of joints and links, typically
around 20 links.
Depending on what actions we choose for these
individual body parts in time, we can construct
movements such as walking, or leaping forward.
However, this time, these creatures not only
learn to walk, but they also monitor their
surroundings and are also taught to cope with
immense difficulties that arise from larger
terrain differences.
This means that they learn both on character
features, like where the center of mass is
and what the velocity of different body parts
are, and terrain features, such as, what the
displacement of the slope we're walking up
on is or if there's a wall ahead of us.
The used machinery to achieve this is deep
reinforcement learning.
It is therefore a combination of a deep neural
network and a reinforcement learning algorithm.
The neural network learns the correspondence
between these states and output actions, and
the reinforcement learner tries to guess which
action will lead to a positive reward, which
is typically measured as our progress on how
far we got through the level.
In this footage we can witness how a simple
learning algorithm built from these two puzzle
pieces can teach these creatures to modify
their center of mass and adapt their movement
to overcome more sophisticated obstacles,
and, other kinds of advertisites.
And please note that the technique still supports
a variety of different creature setups.
One important limitation of this technique
is that it is restricted to 2D.
This means that the characters can walk around
not in a 3D world, but on a plane.
A question whether we're shackled by the 2D-ness
of the technique or if the results can be
applied to 3D remains to be seen.
I'd like to note that candidly discussing
limitations is immensely important in research,
and the most important thing is often not
we can do at this moment, but the long-term
potential of the technique, which, I think
this work has in abundance.
It's very clear that in this research area,
enormous leaps are made year by year, and
there's lots to be excited about.
As more papers are published on this locomotion
problem, the authors also discuss that it
would be great to have a unified physics system
and some error metrics so that we can measure
these techniques against each other on equal
footings.
I feel that such a work would provide fertile
grounds for more exploration in this area,
and if I see more papers akin to this one,
I'll be a happy man.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!